[Music]
the name of the father and the son the
Holy Spirit
am
hello I know God saved me for a reason
but guess I'm still searching for what
that reason
is much brother of
[Music]
Christ it's a
miracle you are with
[Music]
child out of all the women in the
world why did he chose me how can we
trust what's inside you
[Music]
suffering you
L
suffering
yes she
[Music]
loves
you all came highly
recommended you know the rules no real
names no Back
stories no s so whose kid is she a very
wealthy man who's about to be $50
million
poorer I'm here to make sure you're safe
what's your name mine's Abigail you can
call me Joey do you have any kids I have
a little boy see you in 24
hours do you know what a pinky promises
if you behave and do as we
say I pinky promise you it'll all be
over
soon Joey yeah I'm sorry about what's
going to happen to
you what the
[__] [__] we got to get out of
here I think she knows
something
guys
oh what the [__] is that thing we
kidnapped a [__]
[Music]
vampire a ballerina
vampire okay how do we kill a vampire
what are we talking about like an an
rice or a True Blood you know Twilight
steak through the heart daylight is a
big
one all right let's go kill us a [__]
vampire
[Music]
[Applause]
ready what can I say I love like playing
with my
food whoa whoa whoa she's [__]
[Music]
flying I [__] hate
ballet
[Applause]
12 cards in the
circle one more at the
heart with this final
card your meting will start that's
terrifying yeah this old deck is kind of
strange where did you find
them an unspoken rule not to use
somebody else's cards who cares who's
going first
follow one rule to stay out of danger
hello you're never to deal death of
stranger
[Music]
the
magician
who face will you
see when you take your last
[Music]
breath who's
[Applause]
next
how does it feel being back good I had
such good memories here maybe my happy
place can be our happy place we left you
all alone down here it
was I'm playing a new game with chy the
scavenger hunt list that's fun
chy says you're not allowed to play with
us because you left him I need something
happy something
happy G I thought bugs freaked you out
if I can finish my list chy will take me
on a trip to the place he's
[Music]
from something that hurts
Alice
my imagin you've been spending time with
a new
[Music]
friend he asked you to do something that
hurt you that was part of the game does
that seem like a game a good friend
would want to play maybe we shouldn't
play together anymore johy maybe we
shouldn't be friends no no no
no Alice Alice Alice Al Alice
Alice she's lost but we're going to find
her every culture has entities that
tether to the young we call them
imaginary
friends you are always playing with your
imaginary friend when the connection was
severed The Entity becomes
enraged he says he's right behind you
imagin can I hang out with your
imaginary friend he's not
imaginary and he's not your
[Applause]
friend
[Music]
after the night when I wake
up I see what to on
gra
[Music]
you don't have to be
afraid this child is his
way you
such a morbid
imagination bringing dead
things to
life hey she emerges from her cave hello
when do you think you finished this film
with yours I don't
know
what's all that stuff it's called stop
motion animation what do you think it's
a bit boring it's not finished and it's
not boring make a new one a new one yeah
I know better story you want to hear
[Music]
it there's a
girl she's
scared
there's someone
coming who's coming the man no one wants
to meet the
Ashman you can bring it to
[Music]
life what does the Ashman do don't be
scared
whatever it is you think you saw back
there it's not
real I don't want to make this film
anymore do you want to hear the next bit
of the
story I want to go I want to
go what happens when it takes on a life
of its own
[Music]
my dad he
died I'm the solicitor have your
father's
estate my dad owned this
place I don't have any memories with him
this is all I have right
now if you're watching this then I'm
already
[Music]
dead this property comes with a special
tenant you're the one thing that stands
between her and the outside world you're
joking what is that come out come out
wherever you
are
Iris we shouldn't be
here what is
she she has the power to bring back the
Dead I want to see her money's really no
object I want to talk to my
wife she only gives you to 2
minutes sah after that she's in
control what's going
on we are not safe
here how do I control
her this isn't something you can
control
I'm going to kill you you can't kill
her you cannot let her out of the
basement are you hot for
anyone Lisa does he have more of a
basketball b or a football B he doesn't
play
sports my attenda is grave I talk to him
I wish I was with
you that's really weird
[Music]
Lisa you hear I'm sure it's the girl
next door she's very
odd
H your
H I can't believe you're here do you
like music I have the Cure oh not that
kind of cure they can't make you better
I mean they can but like emotionally no
don't cry your tears just smell so
bad send it back you need a
friend I love it it's not really my
style when you're in doubt L looks good
she could probably even do pageants if
she had
Congeniality your daughter has a little
psycho I open my glorious home to an
ungrateful
little I want to help you but Taffy says
it's a waste of time to try and fix a
way he better just accept a guy's father
oh that's so
cute I have an idea there are bad people
out there come on Lisa it'll feel
good that hand is going to do terrible
things I'm sorry but I just
think you are being admitted impatient
lock
down I could get the clink for life or
the electric chair but I don't want to
die a
virgin you know anything about The
Disappearance of a stent
not making any more
comments you can talk to my lawyer
really hope this goth phase in soon you
need a
friend
[Music]
scared
we po do we kiss no he didn't when we
were fixing up the pool
stop they said it hadn't been used in 15
years maybe they weren't cool people
this is not for the
kids used to be scared of
pools cider come on
cider getting a Vibe here do you have a
boyfriend no hey someone's cominging
over in a
minute keep your B shut
Marco
you need to say something
back Ronin
Marco why aren't you saying
anything my kids have seen things
and I'm worried something is happening
to my
husband dad haven't been looking for
you there has to be some way to stop
this
Mar
Elliot
Marco
[Music]
I've been waiting 40 years for this they
called themselves Ghost Busters
according to these hacks they saved the
world no
eyewitnesses and who is found to carry
the torch descendants of Egon Spangler
you have a minor hanging out the side of
a moving vehicle firing a laser gun
indiscriminately has a proton back it's
completely safe I wouldn't say
completely safe the Ghostbusters are
finished right well overruled
sustained thank
you you the weird guy who buy strange
old things correct on both counts buddy
you just hit the
jackpot what is it better question is
what's inside of
it
a The Parables tell of an unimaginable
evil commanding an Army of
Ghosts that's the power to kill by fear
itself like literally scared to
[Music]
death we might be looking at our second
Ice
Age we're going to need all the help we
can get let's get to
work can I be of any help melet in uni
form
yeah is there something
strange if there's something weird what
are people going to call Ghostbusters
what do you
[Music]
want where the Ghostbusters can I tell
you something else what Buster makes me
feel good makes me feel
good
heads up it's all dark and horny at
[Music]
12:00
yeah
are you
okay 32-year-old Beacon Hill resident
Megan rhs had been assumed dead by the
police after she disappeared from a
nearby parking garage nearly 6 months
earlier
sorry my great-grandfather bought this
place in the 20s I
think it's pretty empty in the winter
good I'm really sorry about what
happened to you thank you is anyone else
coming down doubt
it Meg I'm sorry this is my cousin
meline we've got a big family I won't
hold it against
you after what you went through you'll
never feel normal again how are you guys
related her cousins there's just
something off about her what are you
nervous about is it all the talk of
death I think I saw your mother she
hasn't left that room in
[Music]
months you remember what Dr Potter said
sometimes nightmares can feel really
real
why did you bring me
here where were
you when I was
gone you're broken you can't tell what's
[Music]
real
and
[Music]
child
Santa
[Music]
h
show starts in 1
minute to
theob let's all go to the lobby let's
all go to the lobby to get
ourselves someone is killing my
children someone help them on uprooting
life in Fairwood as we know and making
us forget Who We Are where we've come
from right now right
now and now on with the
show deserve the best party that we can
throw I've seen some rejections in my
time but man that was
a there's blood all over the jungle gym
blood
[Music]
yes
yeah he's like completely in love with
me Freddy it's totally disgusting put
the phone down put the phone down please
like no J turn it around please
J I'll be right
back and he's dead
what like if he was in a horror movie
you'd never say I'll be right back cuz
then you
[Applause]
[Music]
don't where the hell did he
go
[Music]
who do we
[Applause]
call I don't know where Grace has got to
Grace
Grace we just have to let the police do
their job they'll have you chid her back
in no time
my daughter went missing your lord does
not have your child then who has taken
my
daughter every year we drive him
out but he stands in the fields and
waits who stands in the fields and waits
Grace a demon didn't take
grace these people are sick you afraid
Vick he's here
you will give us great
Miracles time to Rebel in
chaos you're going to get our little C
back this is how we love the midnight
sun will
rise and you will see his
[Music]
glory
[Applause]
Andes we hand the ramp L
at
[Music]
Turon
dear
B
[Music]
[Applause]
a
[Music]
the
of
fore
look at this welcome to Norway you're
Americans yeah hi hello I can't believe
we inherited this place middle of
[Music]
nowhere there's something in the barn
what do you mean
something so what do you think happened
probably some kids woo that's that's a
barn elfelf are they
real yes first off the barn elf doesn't
like changes to the farm that looks good
secondly he hates bright artificial
light what do you think and he hates
loud
[Music]
noises motion activat
no this is really
bad you're in Norway now okay nothing
bad ever happens
here what's going on here we are under
attack where's your gun I don't have a
gun what this isn't Detroit
Bill what on Earth did you do to make
them so mad we broke all the
rules
what are you going to do about it I'm
going to swipe this area for
fingerprints and then I'll call the
forensics and
[Music]
uh